[Music]
my biggest struggle um in my early 20s
was
believing i understood a concept or a
certain philosophy that i subscribed to
but then consistently not living that
way and not executing those beliefs and
struggling and being depressed or
you know disappointed in life i wasn't
living that way and that's really
frustrating and the problem is that's
all just ego that's ego sneaking in the
back door i think we're all looking to
find out
from an egoic standpoint what our
relevance is who we're supposed to be
what
you know the definition of joy and love
is and purpose i had certain beliefs and
uh desires and i wanted to be a certain
type of person but but a lot of my
thoughts were kind of
um i guess rooted in the ego you know
and when i say the ego i don't
necessarily mean arrogance i just mean
the part of your brain that is the that
says i it's the thinker um and that part
of your brain is very
uh self-serving it lives in a world of
comparisons and uh time and none of
these things are helpful it just kind of
would consistently take me out of
a positive place you know the the man i
wanted to be with the man i thought i
should be or
um you know you're basing who you are
and what you think you should be on who
you'll be tomorrow and who you were
yesterday and as we go through life and
experience trauma we build walls defense
mechanisms and eventually we adopt them
so deeply and you know they are
activated on a daily basis you start
thinking of who you are we are not our
thoughts you know we all have to realize
that the things that go on in our brains
not our true identity how do you create
separation between the two stillness you
know it's not the idea of doership is
misleading to think well what do i have
to do to get where i want to be right
people want to chase it you want you
think to think the person you are is out
there or that you have to you don't have
to do anything everything you want need
is in here right now you just have to
stop for me the the most effective tool
i've adopted is just trying to stay
present when you're in the moment the
part of your brain that thinks in terms
of time just gets quiet kind of doesn't
exist anymore
so a lot of my old hurdles have kind of
become far more manageable by just
staying present someone just kind of
once said shush and it was in response
to me having a bit of an over analytical
question really is about kind of
stealing your brain noise recognizing
that the majority of the stuff you
grapple with uh is just noise and it
reinvents and it's cyclical and it's
it's not you know
it's not turning your back on something
it's it's not kind of
uh quitting or giving up it's kind of uh
letting it kind of wash over you and
then the shush of it all is just kind of
uh being able to cultivate the ability
to to be still and be present and if you
can do that then then circumstance
becomes a little more inconsequential
i'm scared that i won't get where i
think i want to get i'm scared that i
won't know true happiness i'm scared
that i won't know true beauty or love or
but i'm i'm okay having those fears but
i also know at the same time that that's
those aren't real fears i really really
believe that's just
that's the ego talk and that's okay
because my ego has been trained to speak
for 34 years i can't expect to all of a
sudden delete it
from the map today all i got to do is
when those fears come up
recognize that those are ego based fears
i'm totally okay with those things
popping up on the radar because they're
gonna and that's okay too i think that
mentality has gone a long way for me in
terms of just
surrendering to the moment surrendering
to where i am and surrendering even to
my failures you know your failures are
okay too i used to really be very hard
on myself um
if i thought i wasn't
accomplishing something or reaching a
certain level but you know
be with your failures they're just as
educational and just as opening to the
process as the successes um i i probably
started thinking this way when i was you
know maybe
15 16 years old they say you don't
really wake up from dreams you wake up
from nightmares
and not to say my childhood was a
nightmare at all by any means but i
certainly started to see a pattern uh
you know where whatever my struggles or
challenges were at that age if they were
ever kind of
met or satisfied i started to see how
the next day
my brain found new struggles and
challenges uh to be at odds with and you
start to realize how amazingly resilient
that part of your brain is um that that
can just create conflict and truly be at
odds with what is and i i started to
worry that no matter what happened or
where i
went in my life will that always be that
way so for me it's a matter of being
perfectly okay
exactly where i am and practicing it's
like uh
if i was going to try and pick up a
sport
you know i'm not going to be amazing
tomorrow today i just have to dribble
just got to dribble the ball
and if the ball gets away from me today
it's okay get it back and just dribble
again even if it takes all of my focus
and energy just to dribble this ball
maybe tomorrow
it won't and it won't be as
consuming
but but it's okay to be where i am i
don't have to wake up tomorrow and be a
pro success to me feels a bit like a
notion i mean if there's success there's
failure just being happy being peaceful
being content being present i love
being creative i love the business that
i'm in it's it's
absolutely who i was as a child you know
you try and always think what did you do
on a sunday morning when you were a kid
what were you doing when you weren't
doing it for anything you know when you
were just
waking up trying to have fun what were
you doing um that's what you should
probably be doing with your life and
luckily
i was you know putting on shows and
doing theater
so i'm very lucky in the sense that my
profession is also something that is
deeply connected to the part of my life
when
when my brain wasn't so noisy and i
wasn't fueled by ego or
an accomplishment or or this kind of
story that we're trying to tell
ourselves i was just doing it because it
felt fun
the first couple times i tried
meditating very hard because my brain is
so noisy and you know maybe you get a
second two three seconds tops of
sustained still
breathing and presence uh and then very
quickly you know your brain
asks them well am i doing this am i
thinking i'm thinking thoughts right now
and you know you kind of lose it but
that's okay and you go right back to
trying to focus again and uh you know
the more you do it hopefully the the
shorter intervals of brain noise will
happen and the longer periods of time
where you are truly present uh begin to
bloom a little bit the place i'm trying
to get to is
something that the mind can't
comprehend it wants to it really wants
to but it can't it's different languages
it's just
be present don't don't think about
tomorrow don't think about the next
minute just where are you right now
don't miss right now be here now um and
a nice sense of calm just kind of washes
over
i think the thing that i'm looking for
in life is just longer periods of
uh blooming presence
blooming presence all you really have in
life i think is just now a series of
nouns
and i think when you can kind of
surrender to that um
you can't lose but i felt pieces of it
and i know it's good
and i'm chasing it and it's worth it so
uh whatever that is
i guess i'm working to kind of have
longer moments of that
i think happiness is about
trying to live
in the moment and being present a lot of
our suffering i think comes from
analyzing the past and worrying about
the future
and living in our mistakes as if that's
who we are but if you're able to be
present and still those egoic thoughts i
think you can tap into
happiness